We have concluded that any forward edge
from A to B must be saturated, and
any backward edge from
B to A must be unused.
Before going any further,
let's illustrate this with an example.
Here we have a flow on the left and
the corresponding residual
graph on the right.
Note that there is no path from
s to t in the residual graph.
Let's mark the vertices we
can reach from s in green and
the other ones in orange.
Now it's easy to see that all the edges
from the green to the orange vertices
are saturated, and the edges from
the orange to the green are empty,
just like the theorem claims.
Recall that for any cut, the value of
a flow is the flow out of the partition
with the source minus the flow into
the partition with the source.
As we just argued,
however, in this case there is no
flow back into the source partition.
Moreover, the flow
saturates all the edges.
So it's just the sum of the capacities
across the cut from A to B,
which is then defined
as the cut capacity.
That completes the second
part of the theorem.
Lastly, we need to show that
the existence of a cut that has the same
value as a flow implies that
that flow is a maximum flow.
This follows immediately from the fact
that a cut is an upper bound.
If it's not an upper bound, then cut
capacity wouldn't be an upper bound
on the value of the flow, so
this would produce a contradiction.
That then completes the theorem.
These three things are equivalent,
maximum flow is equal to minimum
capacity cut, and the Ford-Fulkerson
approach returns a maximum flow.
If you followed all that,
congratulations.
The Max-Flow Min-cut Theorem
is one of the classic
theorems in the study of algorithms, and
a wonderful illustration of duality,
which we'll discuss in a later lesson.
For now, however, we're not quite
ready to leave maximum flow yet.